- On this episode, I'm
super, super, super excited
because of a Jets win,
and I get really, really, really deep.
(upbeat, hip hop music)
You ask questions, and I answer them.
This is the #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and this is episode 138
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
I am in a very good mood, period,
as my New York Jet,
actually, you know what's really fun?
This is really fun, Staphon.
By the way, Staphon, let's show Staphon.
(laughter)
Trying to get some ladies out of this?
Why not.
Staphon is editing the show now.
DRock, you don't get that street cred,
DRock working on some
of the bigger projects,
Staphon getting in the zone,
helps us get the show out
a little bit sooner, too,
so I think you guys are
benefitting from Staphon's
elevation into this spot.
What I wanna do on Mondays,
regardless of how it worked out or not,
is play the clip, maybe
15 seconds, 8 seconds,
I'll try not to drag them out,
of my official prediction
so we can see it.
So obviously, you just heard
that happen in real time,
so, obviously, I made this prediction.
This Sunday, the Jets go out and beat
the Cleveland Browns, who
have not won an opener
since I think 2004, 19 to seven.
Not bad.
19 to seven, 31-10, not super bad.
12 and 3 points, it's gonna
get way worse than that.
And I'm excited.
I'm heading to Indianapolis,
I'm going to a wedding this weekend
in the Denver area and
then I'll be flying back,
connecting, the whole,
a really tough travel
to get into Indie late, late Sunday night,
and in time for the
Jets' Monday night game
against the Colts, this is my third trip
to Indianapolis for a football game,
both other games were playoff games,
we won one, we lost one,
we lost the one that would've
got us into the Superbowl,
we won a first round game.
That was a good one, though.
Someone to beat Peyton
Manning in his last game
as a Colt, just saying, Colt fans.
And so a great mood,
really pumped that Mulden is okay,
we had a player that looked, like,
really seriously injured,
completely put a cloud on my day,
I'm pumped to see you're okay, Lorenzo,
good luck, feel better.
Antonio Cromartie a
friend and a great Jet,
looks pretty hurt, news in a couple hours,
but I'm fearing he's out for the year,
but otherwise, a tremendous day.
This cute little picture
with me and AJ on Instagram,
and Stunwin listened to the game,
he's clearly lucky, claims to me.
- Yeah, I mean, it's the
first game I ever listened to
and look what happened, so.
- And I'm excited.
We'll see what happens, we continue,
congrats to everybody who won,
sorry to everybody who lost, Giants,
and let's, Jets football,
let's get into the show.
Stunwin.
Video, right off the bat.
Let's do it, a lot of video today.
- Hey, Gary, this is John McAlpine,
reaching out to you from Toronto, Ontario.
My question for you here
- T-Town
- is in regard to my
father-in-law's business.
My father-in-law is from
Minsk, Belarus, originally,
so his English is very poor
and moved here about three years ago,
but he's an amazing, fantastic contractor,
and he wants to grow his
business, and I wanna help him.
So, given the scope of,
let's say, about $1,000,
because we're really small,
what are some baby steps you could suggest
me, as a marketer of his business, to do
so I can help him out and so we can
start gaining some traction here.
You keep answering our questions, Gary,
and I promise we'll keep asking.
Thanks for everything you do.
- John, great question.
Obviously, you know how
to hit my emotional center
by going back to the old country.
And that's a great, great question,
and a real practical one.
And $1,000, I think, is
really so much more realistic
for a lot of people that listen.
Way more the clients that
we have here on Vayner,
spending hundreds of
thousands, millions of dollars
each month in different
marketing activities.
Couple different things.
Number one, I noticed
you said a heavy accent,
which made me believe
that you were alluding to
don't give me the advice
to put him on camera or put him out there.
Now, if his personality is like my mom's,
who never shows up,
actually asked my mom for the first time
at the Jets game yesterday, I said,
mom, I think it might be time for you
to be on the show
and make your first ever appearance.
She said no, she really,
it's just not her thing.
And so that crushed my heart, mom,
and you crushed the entire
Vayner Nation's heart, mom,
they all want you to be on the show.
So, now, if his accent is something
you're worried about but
he's willing to do content
and become Bob Vila, which,
I know you're in Canada,
but I think Vila might be an
international star, right,
but if you don't know
who it is, look it up,
he became like the home,
he became America's
contractor in the 80s on PBS,
when people weren't
doing the kind of content
we see on cable these days,
when chefs and real estate
agents became famous,
and so I would put, I
would make videos of him,
if he's that great of a
contactor, and I believe you,
I think, you know, you
get different skills
from different parts of the world,
he'll bring a little of
that Eastern European flair
or soundness or whatever that angle is
to the Canadian building market.
I think you put him on and start
doing Bob Vila-like videos.
Now, with $1,000, I would
spend that on the 10, 15, 20,
30 mile radius of your guys' area
to get those videos out
to people that are fans
of things like Architectural Digest
or things that are into
building and interior design,
into the culture of home
building, contract work,
renovations, things of that nature,
so, now, if he's not
willing to go on camera
because he's introverted,
shy, worried about his accent,
I know a lot of those variables,
you need to figure out how to make content
that is compelling to people,
maybe you translate his
advice into written form,
and then you run ads on
Facebook in a 20 mile radius,
'Did you know you could fix
cabinets by doing this?'
'Replacing new floors.'
And you gotta target
people based on interests
that may find that interesting.
Content is the gateway
drug for small businesses,
that don't have a lot of money,
have to put out great
contents, spend little dollars,
just like I did with Wine Library TV,
but now there's more things.
Instagram accounts, those kinds of things,
that's what I would do.
- [Voiceover] Matt McLeod asks,
"Gary, you talk about in your early years,
"you didn't say anything
and just built your brand.
"How do you know when to
switch to the next level?"
- You know, I think, you know, listen.
There's a lot of people who never switch.
Who says you have to switch to
become an outward personality
or you want to, I wanted
that, I love, you know,
mom, you'll like this,
because I know you're watching
now that I mentioned you and
you're paying extra attention.
You know, my mom loved me so much,
to such a high level, I
feel that I'm a good guy
because I want the love and
admiration from all of you
because I still want that
feeling, I like that feeling,
and it's crazy, I'm starting
to really, really understand
that that's what, I'm like, why am I,
why do I even care to be a good guy
when it's so easy not to?
It's because I really like
the feeling of being loved.
I mean, just, it's super,
and there's only one way
to do that, which is
to provide love first.
And so, you know, I
think that making that,
I needed that, I needed
to be out in the open,
mass love or whatever I'm looking for,
but not everybody needs that.
Do you know how many people,
for every Mark Cuban or
Richard Branson, right,
for every one of those
kinds of entrepreneurs
that are out there, you know,
there's so many that you've never heard of
building hundred, do you know
how many people right now
have a hundred million dollar business,
a five hundred million dollar business,
that you've literally never heard of?
Countless.
Go look at Forbes 400 richest people.
You'd be flabbergasted how many of them
you've never heard of.
So, you don't have to make the switch
to become a personal
brand, or be out there,
you know, do you know how many people
push the other way, who never wanna be,
use the money, actually, to not be known?
They just wanna keep getting the money.
It depends what drives you.
Money is fine, but its a
byproduct of what drives me,
which is building community,
creating a legacy,
empowering people, it's equally selfish
as it is, you know, noble, and so
I think, first, it starts
with knowing yourself
and recognizing you don't have to.
One could argue that
if I didn't need that,
I'd have a 500 million dollar
wine business right now.
So it's not necessarily always
about making more money,
it's about checking the
boxes that make you happy.
Like, going to a Jets game.
That makes me very happy.
Steve, you'll love this one.
- Hey there, boring and
three-dimensional Gary.
I just wanted to know two things.
First of all, what are you
going to do with yourself
now that I'm taking over this show.
You see that, DRock,
I think I made him cry.
But, also, what are some
of the biggest changes
that have happened since
I came out with my book,
Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook?
- Great question, great work.
Steve, why don't you
tell the story real quick
on how this amazing
cartoon came to fruition.
- I tweeted something
about an obscure video game
from the 90s.
- [Gary] Which one?
- A game called the Neverhood,
there's a Kickstarter
coming out called Armor
Crog, and this random guy,
this, like, random guy was just like,
oh, yeah, I'm really excited
for that to come out, too.
We started going back and forth,
and I followed him, and all of a sudden,
he made one of these, like,
random, custom things
and made a video saying
'thanks for following me.'
And I was like, this is ridiculous,
I dare you to make you Gary.
And he did, and we ended
up going back and forth,
and he ended up asking a question.
- That's amazing.
I mean, he jabbed you.
- [Steve] He jabbed me.
- I love it, I love it.
Do you know what chrono trigger is?
- [Steve] Of course.
- Just wanted to show you I do, too.
(laughter)
A lot of things have changed
since Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook.
As a matter of fact, as I was writing it,
the paid volume of importance on
paid in Facebook, was happening
as Jab, Jab, Jab, Right
Hook was being written,
and organic reach was
dropping, I was like, oof,
and Instagram was becoming more obvious
to me as a mainplay,
which is why I brought it
to the front of the book.
You know, obviously, Instagram
now has paid right now,
Pinterest, I think I
understand better than I did
when I wrote Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook,
I would've done more search engine process
and understanding for Pinterest.
Snapchat would've become
enormously important part
of Jab, Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook Two,
Snapchat would be at the
forefront, I would do more
B to B stuff, I think I
understand that better,
and would do more LinkedIn content.
YouTube wasn't even a part of it.
I probably would acknowledge
it more, jam with it,
so Facebook has become even more important
and more powerful, I
would argue that Twitter's
become less powerful,
so, yeah, I mean, that's the point, right.
I try to write, you know, it's funny,
the new book that's coming out March,
#AskGaryVee, the book,
is probably gonna be
the most ever green book.
No, Thank You Economy is an
outrageously evergreen book,
but Jab, Jab, Jab,
Right Hook and Crush It!,
to a degree, thank you econ,
I mean, all the books I write tend to have
that 24 to 48 month lifecycle,
and then I feel like they need updating,
and so I put out a lot of free content
like I do here to make
sure I'm providing value.
I take an enormous responsibility
for somebody who spent $15 to buy my book,
to bring them value.
I do that by subsidizing
a product like this
for free, forever.
You see that look I gave it there?
By the way, Staphon
should really have to be
in the filming of every episode.
I recognized, after the
other day, the Jet episode,
like, there's a disadvantage for him not,
because all the subtle things
makes him have to pay attention way more,
where as here, now, he
can either take notes
or mental notes, it'll be a lot easier.
New rule alert.
Staphon.
(sirens)
- [Steve] Kyle asks, if Lizzie had a.
- That was super meta.
- [Steve] That was really meta.
(laughter)
- [Voiceover] Kyle Reed asks,
"if Lizzie had a successful business,
"what would you do to
support and encourage her?"
- So, self-awareness is important,
I will say this, this is
gonna be really interesting
to see how everybody handles this answer.
As long as Lizzie's business
was smaller than mine,
I would, don't forget,
I say the following and
I say it all the time.
I wanna build the
biggest building in town.
I'm obsessed with it.
I wanna do that by building
the biggest building in town.
And I've no interest in tearing down
anybody else's business.
I would 100% struggle if
Lizzie ran a business,
and it was financially
more successful than mine.
It would absolutely cripple me.
Just, the truth.
And so the question becomes,
I would help it with
all my heart and soul,
but God forbid I even feel any indication
that it was about to pass
whatever I was up to,
I would pull out of there,
and then start undermining
it in weird ways
to make sure that wouldn't happen.
This is tough, right, I
mean, it's just the truth.
I mean, and listen, I married Lizzie
because I knew what I was looking for
in a partner, in a spouse, like,
but people change, I don't think Lizzie,
maybe I didn't even realize
how insanely workaholic
it would become.
I mean, I thought I was
working a lot before,
so things change.
It's interesting, though, I will say this,
and this really is an interesting
part of the whole thing,
even I'm fascinated by it.
There's a part of me that's sad
about what I'm about to say.
I would be way better about it
today than I would've been five years ago.
I can feel it.
And it scares me to think
would I be willing to do maybe
even 10 or 15 years from now.
I feel like it, I feel like
it's like a competitive
softening, and I think it's
true, at least with Lizzie.
Not for any of these guys, like,
I'd kill Staphon, like, physically, dead.
Like, you know, so,
that's the truth, I would do,
as long as I felt that it was
not gonna be as big as my businesses,
I would give her anything
in the world, period.
But there's a very dark,
competitive side to me
when it comes to business.
And I have friends who
have much more successful
businesses, and it's stunning to me
how happy I am for them.
Like, I wouldn't have
thought that 20 years ago,
but it doesn't mean
that I don't think about
every day beating them,
and I want it badly.
I don't know if I'd be able to handle that
with a spouse, though.
Yeah, I just,
that's not what I was
looking for in a partner.
Really, I was looking
for somebody who really
was the CEO of our family,
somebody that I didn't feel like I had,
I compete with everybody in the world.
You know what kind of,
what kind of comfort zone
my wife is for me?
Like, I compete with
everybody in the world.
She's my teammate, I don't wanna be forced
by my own craziness to compete with her.
So, that's what would happen.
Yeah, yeah, real talk.
This show got real.
Like, I'm very self aware enough
to know that's not gonna be
the most politically correct
answer, but I take a lot of pride
in that this show's
forced me to tell truths
all the way through, and,
I secretly hope nobody in my family
will ever watch that answer.
No, I think everybody, you know,
I think everybody, you know what?
I don't know if I would've
answered this question
in episode 20.
You know, I think I
would've dodged it maybe.
Even being, I wanna be as
as, I'm going real raw now
I probably would've
danced a little bit more.
I just feel at this point,
this collective audience,
this could be your first episode,
but this collective audience's starting
to really understand who I am,
and that's just the truth.
I wonder eh, as I say it out loud,
I probably would've answered it.
Let the chips fall.
The truth is just always the best spot.
- [Steve] Alright, last question.
- Did you think that's what was coming?
- [Steve] I don't know!
But it makes sense, I know tons of people,
when couples are in the
same industry together,
that comes up.
- Sure.
I just compete with
everything and everybody.
Like, like, my dad, my siblings,
like, I can already feel it
brewing with my children,
I just need Liz to be,
I just need one partner.
- [Steve] Is that why
you went into business
with AJ, because the idea of him.
- You know, that's an
interesting question.
You know what's funny?
I actually think AJ can
build bigger businesses
than I can, because I think
of the way he's wired
allows him to create a, I see
AJ being much more capable
to build a 500 dollar software,
500 million dollar software company,
I see AJ having the kind of makeup,
especially now, actually,
I think the best way
for me to have not had AJ compete with me
is to have never gone
into business with him.
Because then he would've
never learned the things
that I've been teaching him,
and rounding out that kind of,
the magic array, I think
he's now in a position
to really give me a run.
See?
Older brother, you love yours.
Like, trust me, if I
was the younger brother,
I would've been like no way.
It's getting deep here on a Monday.
Let's go, Chase.
- Hey, what's up, Gary, it's Chase Jarvis.
I've got a question for you, my man,
but give me one second first.
So, I'm a photographer and a director,
and I'm also the CEO of Creative Live,
which is the world's largest
live streaming education company.
My question is about creativity
and what role does creativity play
in business in the future
of business leadership
and strategy.
Please tell me, man, I'm dying to know.
- Well, Chase, let's talk about strategy.
When you are a Seattle Seahawks fan
in the last 36 months,
and you decide to finally send the video
that we've been waiting
for for a year now,
on maybe the only Sunday
in the last 36 months,
on the Monday after a Sunday
where the Jets won and the Seahawks lost,
I would argue, if
somebody's nerdy about this,
please tell me the other weekends,
and there's probably, I
mean, the Seahawks lost
like, two, three games
a year for the last two,
so maybe serendipitously,
but there is probably the
likelihood of, 16, 48,
you know, a 48 Monday shows after Sundays,
there was probably three, maybe two,
that have the situation
that we had yesterday,
where you put on a Seahawks jersey
and dissed the Jets, right, like,
that makes me so happy that your timing
is so off strategy that
you so poorly planned
the strategy of this video,
it makes me happy with that
move that you just pulled.
Creative strategy, I forgot the question.
I blacked out with the
Jets thing, gotta get done.
What role does, give me the punchline?
And replay it, Staphon.
- My question is about
creativity and what role
does creativity play in business,
in the future of business
leadership and strategy.
Please tell me, man, I'm dying to know.
- I mean, Chase, first
of all, an amazing guy,
every photographer watching should watch,
every entrepreneur should
catch up with Chase,
he's an amazing guy.
Creativity is the variable of success.
All the strategies you
create come to the punchline.
This is a creative process, this show.
This content, content
is a creative output,
and everything you planned to that moment,
you could have the greatest strategy ever
to ask that girl out, right, ever.
Like, planned out everything,
but that moment where
you go in for the ask,
that content is the variable possibly
of a yes or no, right,
there's other variables,
but, you know, creativity
is the absolute variable.
Like, you might've understood
who you're going after,
what to do, when to
release that video game,
let's make it Steve-esque,
but if the graphics suck,
or the gameplay suck, or if it sucked,
like, creativity is
the variable of success
in our society.
Including things that we
don't have control of.
Like, if you were just born gorgeous,
if you're just a massively
good looking dude,
right, your strategy might've
sucked on that ask out,
but your creativity, the creative,
maybe the words sucked, but what you said
might've just been enough, like,
you're just a pretty
boy, you're just pretty.
I mean, you know how that is, Staphon.
I mean, guy's got no game, but he wins,
he's just pretty.
(laughter)
I mean, look, that's real,
and you know what's funny, actually,
using looks and the way
you spit game to girls
is actually a tremendous concept
of strategy and creativity.
Like, the way ugly dudes
get chicks is strategy
and the creativity of
their words and charisma.
Just the way it is, I know.
And so, that's that.
Statement of the day,
give me some statements.
This show was action packed
with a bunch of stuff.
Happy New Year to all of
you that are celebrating,
and I wish you a tremendous week.
Indianapolis, I'm coming to see you.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
I had an ex-girlfriend
that I dated in 2001,
in 2002, text me yesterday, she's like,
with her family, she's like,
I just want you to know something,
you changed the course of my life.
I'm a real, hardcore Jets fan.
(upbeat, hip hop music)